[Music]
how's it going my name
is an editor at a small publishing
office let's not interrupt a nipple guy
he's talking look pupp is in the
background all
right hope this video doesn't get flag
because there were boobies in the
background I'm just saying anyway now I
can talk Jesus Christ I ended in a
really bad spot how's it going bros my
name
is oh I we get to save geek room nope
we're going to save it why can't I move
game why can't I
move I swear to God if I play this
chapter I'll smack
someone really hard in the butt in the
real butt don't you dare don't oh thank
God hey we're back to the nipple guy all
right
lovely uh-oh there's someone behind her
oh he's like nice titties nice
titties I like
that all right what's going on here he's
going to rub rub I have to go I'll
contact you something oh it all makes
sense now see you later oh
damn my nipples is almost falling out
all right I like is running by the way
that's how all people oh there he is all
right let's follow that little
shut down I'm sick of your ghost
come here all right where did he go up
or down up or down buddy how how am I
supp supposed to no oh
okay you scar me all right let's
follow this shut down I'm sick of
your
I I was seriously smack him up
smack sadow
up I'm sorry sto doing that left or
right I don't know the Savitt cat is
there so let's go
here
sowow where have you gone to S down s we
used to be friends and then you just
became really Ghostly and
weird I don't really like you anymore CH
da I'm sorry sorry but someone had to
say it sooner or later you keep scaring
at girls titties I don't know why you
would do that where the is he where
the is he where the shut down
I don't even know how that actually
rhymed holy I'm good at rhyming I
bet you're jealous I can tell you're
just sitting that oh man I wish I could
ride that good why are you Whispering
really sorry sorry I didn't mean to find
you I'm just trying to find Zada maybe
he's oh he's not there Z I'm sick of
this
so all right it's got to be over
here all right there's something going
on
here Shadow did you turn on the
TV
Shadow
hello what is this the note no it's not
no what ah it's this again I don't
want to do this ah come
on all right I went to question the
principal after according to him
thep the Nerf's office it's worth
checking out okay I don't remember where
the Nerf office was but uh let's go
there then cuz he told me to the nipple
guy told me but so that was pretty
pointless here but okay oh
uh-oh oh oh don't you dare think I
forgot about you and your she stole my
notebook uh-oh he made a oh oh no they
got they're like let's rape
him I'm going to rape him he's mine oh
no
that's from the ceiling that's
cheating ah
oh now we have to deal with this little
all right let's go to the Nerf
Nerf office where is the Nerf office up
no
maybe ha I escaped that like a boss they
don't even
recognize oh no they're following
me don't what are you doing stop uh-oh
no that all of you
off
stop chasing me it's not fair holy
where's the nurse
office holy my
macaronis ceiling
where's the Nerf
office
Nerf God damn
everyone me SL get
hel holy stop please it's not funny what
if I
crouch me
me you're annoying please make why would
you stop I didn't do anything she just
wants oh I know I have really oh she
wants this no you can't have it
okay fine I got this no problem no
problem no problem no
problem ah stop it oh you little
knock it off holy you're so
obnoxious I'm going to die this
continues all right we need to find the
stairs I think we need to go up or down
up or down up or down up or down up up
it's up definitely for
thank heavens thank heavens all Lord
Mighty all right I made it out of Al
stupid ceiling crawler
ha I think I'm safe and my nipples are
safe too I wonder if that girl is okay
oh he almost said my name wow I can't
really hear you though
all right maybe his nipples were
talking oh he's like oh time to check my
cell phone got any TW check twx all
right calling hello
wait all right we're calling
someone
hello B stop sorry keep doing
that holy answer are already I
ain't got all day there she's not
picking up I hope she's
okay she obviously doesn't like me God
damn it all right what should we
do okay let's look at our nurse
office where's the Nerf office is it
here are you a Nerf no that's cooking
preparation room it's obvious py
sorry but where could it
be and you're not say all maybe perhaps
it's over here that does not look like a
Nerf off in my opinion if if I'm allowed
to have one I don't know you what so
mean you're like P can have a teen I'm
like no it's okay with me oh look how
many lock
that's some awesome I wonder how
many hours I wasted in this
hallway walking around like an idiot
trying to find out what to do can I oh I
can walk higher let's go higher then I
mean why not it all makes sense no to
think about it like uh no I don't think
this is right but what oh we can't even
go here game why do you make me go here
if you can't even uh you
disappoint me Gravely game really look
at this flashlight look at this and
spinning it and charging it by spinning
it look at this beautiful be absolutely
gorgeous all right plant how you doing
can you tell me oh Mara lovely lovely
girl on the post too actually no she's
pretty ugly all right
um any W know whether nurse preparation
room could be
perhaps uh oh yeah wait I know where the
nurse preparation room
why don't I have my uh notebook
oh she stole my
notebook oh I'm pissed how dare she
steal my notebook maybe this is
it
nope God damn
it I'm swimming around in the
corridor
uhoh sit down that St sit down I'm
pissed I'm sick of your
all right he's going to the computer
room so we are going there too
apparently did he lock the door or did
he open the door he open sow sow there's
no time for hexing computer all
right oh we got to record a message
let's do this
[Music]
all
right what the heck is this it's my
penis a counter no it's my penis Jesus
Christ so hard about this sight I was
expecting a lot more hey don't install
my penis a hidden link somewhere I guess
if you try dig deeper I don't think
there anything here
that's I'm hungry now let's go some ice
cream no I why is there so much hype
about a website like this man I thought
it would be more
entertaining what no look the screen
just changed yeah she became
bigger all right that's the girl's first
experience with the penis lovely
absolutely lovely it's beautiful
beautiful U all right let's read this I
need to tell Mak what what's going on I
am super confused this is mind
me right now uh-oh what is this uhoh oh
no Anders L I'm sorry
okay
oh that's a lot of dots holy is
that dude
D oh no he's like talking to me holy
I'm shatting with the and my
nipples is almost falling out God damn
it what are you trying to tell me
S no oh it no
response Snappy SN snap that was that
was some hardcore right there
Snappy snow I'm just going to
back off and be like no sir no
sir all right but there's got to be
something from there all right let's do
a save and let's exit this
s
ah
no ah
ah my toe just ah son ah they ah I
should wear a freaking protection
and Son of a
why can't even talk when that happens no
no no no not again a
you what do you want from
me oh sow I hate you why would you Oh
you's I come back here my toe my
freaking toe titty toe what do you want
from me computer he left a note yeah
okay you all right let's call that
phone number Splendid let's call
that number in the next episode we will
see the final you like this by the way
my made me Weir all right anyway hope
like fav if you enjoyed subscribe to
come bro today and I'll see you in the
next episode of the calling or another
video most
[Music]
likely
oh